let's go to our caller from the 503 area
code who's there from 503 today 503 are
you muted or I don't know okay hi
stephen go hey so maybe somebody's
already done it but I was up early get
talking about the Ilhan Lamar tweet
controversy sure okay so um I wanted to
talk about that being anti-semitic trope
and kind of your view on it do you do
you think she was invoking that on
purpose or was it kind of inadvertent I
don't know I mentioned in my segment
that I don't I don't know whether she
was deliberately fomenting an
anti-semitic trope or not and that I
don't know whether she's personally
anti-semitic or not gotcha okay so my
opinion on it was that she wasn't just
because the context of the conversation
was around the Israeli lobbying presence
in the u.s. is it fair to say that if
we're bringing up anti-semetic trope it
should be about the Jewish race or
religion or people rather than that
sorry if we're bringing up anti-semitic
tropes then what should be about the
Jewish race are really the within the
context on the conversation so if if
we're talking about like a government
okay
versus the religion can we still be
anti-semitic as criticizing those things
or is it different well it depends on
what the context is I mean there's this
phrase that people like to talk about
which is anti being anti Israeli is not
anti-semitic and of course that's true
in a sort of literal sense but there is
anti-israeli sentiment that is pretty
weak cover for anti-semitism so there's
no one answer I mean definitionally an
anti Israeli statement is of course not
anti-semitic okay I just want to start
by Zola there's a lot of comments you
know about that particular Church and
just straight forward I think there's a
lot of miscommunication between you and
the audience in terms of like where
people
I think a lot of the audience land on
the side of she wasn't specifically
talking about the Jewish race or
religion or people and so therefore that
tweet wasn't anti-semitic but to me it
seemed like your point was you know Jews
plus money is an old trope that's
existed for a long time and that's true
no matter what right it's not a question
of its I mean it listen it's true no
matter what that that trope has existed
for a long time it's more than just
looking at one tweet and analyzing what
exactly was in her head you have to look
at the combination of both tweets the
reality that it all started related to
this Republican congressman Kevin
McCarthy who has not actually received
any money from AIPAC even though her
second tweet said that the money is
coming from
AIPAC it you have to look at it more
systemically and I'm totally fine if the
audience is more in disagreement with me
on this issue than with others you know
I think that the most important thing
that that I would say is I don't sort of
restate my views differently merely
because we find a point of greater
disagreement with the audience I think
that's how a lot of people end up sort
of putting themselves into positional
corners merely because they're trying to
kind of calculate what will their
audience like best it's great and it's
fine if we have areas where the audience
more agrees with me or less agrees with
me as long as we're sort of like having
reasonable discussions in good faith
about it kind of like you and I have
been doing in the last few minutes right
yeah and that's something that eyes
appreciate about the work that you've
done I disagree with you on this I think
that's pretty clear at this point but
I'm not gonna stop watching your show i
watch every single episode all right
there I did what some people have some
people have canceled their memberships
as a result of that story and I'm glad
I'm glad you're not
yeah I did have one final question and
I'll ask if this is a fair opinion to
have when it comes to McCarthy says he's
a minority leader and it's true that
he's not received any AIPAC funds is it
fair to say that he could be influenced
by those funds because his uh you know
fellow colleagues do you see
those funds and he's in a leadership
position it's a totally reasonable
assertion to make but if that's your
defense you really should be able to
demonstrate exactly how rather than to
just kind of generally say that's
probably what she meant and therefore
it's okay because it's a very
speculative defense yeah I got that but
in my mind when I was thinking it over
if that's the first thing that went
through but you know you're the master
bringing these things down so I wanted
to run it by you here's the thing you
know here's a really important thing and
this comes from from moral psychology
all of us myself included we very
frequently do what are called post facto
rationalizations we believe that the
facts are leading us to our opinions but
very very frequently we have an initial
reaction that comes from sort of passion
or gut or instinct and then we look to
rationalize it after the fact my concern
and hearing you say well he could still
be influenced indirectly by colleagues
who are a PAC funded is that it strikes
me as one of those post hoc
rationalizations
yeah that's extremely vague and that
could be just abused in any number of
subjects so that's why I immediately
question myself I want to ask you about
it as well yeah all right well thank you
I appreciate the call thanks so much for
calling in we will take a quick break if
you're holding don't hang up because we
are going right back to the phones after
the break a quick break and right back
after this